[Musique]
il ya des protocoles qui sont en cours
dans les écoles dans plusieurs
départements visant à éviter de devoir
fermer des classes lorsqu'il ya un cas
positif aujourd'hui tout cela repose sur
de l'auto déclaration de la part des
élèves ou des parents d'élèves auprès du
corps enseignant ce qui rend le
dispositif fragile et qui ne permet pas
d'envisager une généralisation dans
d'autres dans des bonnes conditions
[Musique]
pourquoi mettre fin un principe
fondamental qui est celui du secret
médical au sein de l'école vous ouvrez
monsieur le ministre une brèche
impensable dans un secret qui doit être
conservé j'avoue que je suis quand même
particulièrement alerté par cet
amendement du gouvernement qui
viole le secret médical d'une manière
extrêmement grave
[Musique]